welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul now let's turn it up to
11 and get into stranger
things the latest news from the upside
down is now here and with filming
underway I thought we'd look at
everything we know about the show
throughout this video we're going to be
going through all that we've learned as
well as the official announcements and
leaks on the series if you enjoy the
video please hit that upside down
dislike button and make sure you
subscribe without the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
stranger
things all right so the announcement
that season 5 was being short came from
The Stranger Things Instagram with a
posting the following this is a Cod red
stranger things five production has
officially
begun in the post we also got the
casting crew and on the whole they all
kind of look like how we left them we
can see Hopper still got a shaved ha
head and that's Steve's hair is also
similar too which I kind of feel bad for
him having to rock that but this makes
me think the series might pick up almost
immediately after the events of season 4
though there are some slight differences
that you might notice finin wolf hard's
hairs are a hell of a lot shorter and
Milly Bobby Brown's hairs so long we're
going to have to get those Clippers out
sorry now because of this fans were
going back and forth over whether we get
a time Jump and the wor theories this
could be set in the 90s however I don't
think that's the case with David
Harbor's shaved head indicating things
are continuing wolf hard can get a
bloody wig and you you could even make
one out of Millie Bobby's Hair to be
fair now he's obviously going to just be
having shorter hair which we saw in one
of the behind the set photos it shows
him Sat on a stool and he can even catch
a poster for a New Hope in the back this
poster was from before it was called A
New Hope and it brings a tear to my eye
cuz I actually used to have
one all magazine brought up an interview
with the do Brothers where they talked
about how they were going to handle the
cast aging they said they weren't going
to be using dhing and instead we're
going to rely on hair and makeup on top
of this Roser also posted a picture on
Instagram showing that they had a stick
of a Haley's Comet the dates on this are
November 85 to April 86 and we know that
season 4 was set in March 86 because of
this I think the time jumps out the
question and thus we will just remain in
the 80s and pick up where we left off if
you love the 80s then I think you're
going to like this and please bear with
us for 70 seconds while we shout out the
video sponsor hey now this video is
sponsored by fan home who just launched
an amazing new thing where you can build
your own ET the Extraterrestrial you
know we love covering the classics at
the channel and I was so hyped when
these guys hit me up because ET it's one
of my favorite movies ever back in the
80s the adorable alien captivated movie
goers and became an icon for an entire
generation and now he's back and you can
show your love for et by assembling this
amazing replica of him coming in at 26
in tall they' got sound effects and
phrases from the movie lights in his
finger and chest an extendable and
retractable neck movable arms movable
face and also a movable mouth you can
also remote control them for some action
and the language section pre-order this
amazing replica Now by using my link in
the description and the code spoilers
with that you'll get an exclusive free
gift if you subscribe today that is the
ET extraterrestrial backpack which is
available now for a limited time only
assembly stage 1 is just 195 to
subscribe and assembly stage 2 with that
comes absolutely free like I said you'll
also get the backpack as well so
definitely check out my link in the
description use the code spoilers get
building this cuz it it's incredible
huge thank you to Fan home for
sponsoring this video now let's get back
into the breakdown thanks on top of this
we also had a photo release showing the
script for the opening of season 5 this
says Darkness the sound of cold wind
groaning trees in a child's Voice
singing a familiar song now people have
been going back and forth over what this
is but shout outs to stranger frames for
what I think has nailed it this is Will
singing should I stay or should I go
which comes from season 1 episode 7 it
makes me wonder if we're going to flash
back to the upside down and see vcam
manipulating things behind the scenes as
we learn he was the one controlling it
all and th they might want to wreck on
him so it makes a bit more sense they
did a similar thing during season 4 with
us of course getting 11's backstory lace
throughout the season Netflix also
recently posted the cover of the script
and we know the episode's going to be
called the crawl that takes cnth time
you time back
in So winter on Twitter theorize that
this could be in odd to the lyrics of
Master of Puppets by the band Metallica
in that we hear come crawling faster
obey your master jumping off from this
it's been thought that will might be
called back to vear in the series and
that there'll be elements of Mind
Control we have heard from the leaks
that Will's going to play a big part and
does it makes sense to start with him as
well OB we see Noah schnaps been causing
a schnap storm online and it's going to
be interesting to see if that's still
the case due to these shows often being
Rewritten while in production I feel
like either way we'll obviously get a
strong focus on 11 and that might be
what takes us through the main Trust of
it I really feel like eight might return
from season to and that we could see
things coming full circle from that
Beckner could be wreck on there too and
yeah let me know your thoughts Below on
how they're going to handle it honestly
I I just hope it's about Eddie coming
crawling out Al but that's a few time at
time I'll be back in
time be your
master on top of this we also got a clip
released back in September with the
account also saying something sweet is
coming even got the board with you suck
on there and yeah I'm scratching my
theory times off trying to figure out
what's going on let me know below if you
do and if we do a follow-up video then
we'll promise to give you a shout out
can tell your mates can tell your
parents can tell the girl at the bar and
probably pull a [__] 10 mate shabow
the season 4 really ramed up the
production scale with those final two
episodes being massive events I remember
them being like the finale is going to
be a featur l film and I was just
thinking that they might be talking [__]
but now that finale was 142 minutes long
with it really showing how much the
series had grown I'm kind of expecting
something similar in this series with
them really ramping up their own times
and what they're able to do production
wise you can see a major difference from
season 1 and four and I'm expecting that
Evolution to carry on here Show's
producer Shan Levy recently told total
film that you can expect season 5 to
expand on what's come before huge shout
outs to Al magazine for compiling all
his quotes and they also brought up that
he said this as well it's a major major
cinematic storytelling that happens to
be called a TV series stranger things 5
is as big as any of the biggest movies
that we see on top of this I'll dive
deep into interviews with the D Brothers
to talk about their plans for the season
normally it's like oh we get to revisit
the characters in their normal lives and
how they're doing and what are their
relationships like and five is just
going to be pedal to the metal from the
opening scene at least that's what I
remember from the outline we do have an
outline for season 5 and we pitched it
to Netflix and they really responded
well to it I mean it was hard it was the
end of the story I saw Executives crying
who I've never seen cry before and it
was wild it's not just to do with a
story just the fact of it's like oh my
God this thing has defined so many of
our lives these Netflix people who've
been with us from the beginning 7 years
now it's hard to imagine that Journey
coming to an end now yeah we do know
that the show will be finishing with the
fifth season which is something that's
often been talked about David harier
confirmed this as well with him saying
that he's happy to close his chapter
after 9 years he stay the upcoming
season was going to be the most
difficult thing he'd done in terms of
scale and that we'd also take a closer
look at Hopper he said there's a lot of
complexities revealed in him and that
we're going to look at the character's
finer details guessing that we're going
to learn more of his backstory which is
something that they haven't touched upon
massively we know that he was drafted
into Vietnam and that the character was
part of the chemical corpse we also know
that he had a rough childhood and both
of these things are ripe to explore
could really help to inform us of why he
is the way years and I'd love to see
that for some meaty character
development as with every series we're
going to be getting some new characters
including the legendary Linda Hamilton
we've got breakdowns of both Terminator
films on the channel now and I think
she's going to bring a lot into the show
she's of course an 80s icon and it was
met with great success when they
announced her to Doom back in June
unfortunately we don't know who she'll
be playing yet but I'm really excited to
see her in the show that group shot also
shows sad sink is back which was a big
thing hanging over the end of season 4
really excited to see where they go with
it and hope she's running up that hill
she's running up that road she running
up that build come on really need to
arrest my voice CU you probably he I've
got a cold H shouldn't be doing that but
it was worth it cuz I know you guys hit
the thumbs up button over that's singing
now as for the release date
unfortunately we've got a big gap
between seasons and we've pretty much
watched those kids growing up in front
of us when season 4 released in 2022
Harbor did theorize it'd start shooting
in 2023 he then said based off how it
tends to work that it meant they'd have
it out about mid 2024 unfortunately the
Riders and actor strike slowed it all
down and as they' just started shooting
this month it's going to be delayed so I
expect the series now to probably
release mid 2025 unless they split those
Seasons up again you might remember with
season 4 that they released into parts
and lot of shows seem to be doing that
these days you is doing it not you H
Invincible is as well and it just means
they can make more money with people
subscribing for longer it also means
they get more time to finish up the
latter part of the season so yeah that's
how I imagine that it's going to go
however if they are making stuff bigger
and better then it also makes sense that
the season might take longer too if they
have more feature length episodes in
this one then we're probably going to
see a bigger delay still we're I'm
holding out for that mid toat half of
2024 release which breaks my heart a bit
but I'm just having to be realistic
anyway that wraps up the video and huge
thank you for coming on this journey
Becker before you wreck yourself and
make sure you drop a comment below
giving us your thoughts Please Subscribe
and if you want to support the channel
as a member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
you want to get some heavy spoilers
merch we've also got our t-shirt line
located below the video that will let
you pick up all kinds of tops like
called Theory time one house of dragon
stuff Marvel teasing a lot more you drop
new designs on there all the time too so
definitely keep an eye out and thank you
for your support now if you want some
else to watch you've got a video on
screen right now so definitely head over
there right after this without way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I'll be your host Paul I see you next
time take care peace